along Bangladeshis border with india
people-smuggling has suddenly become a
booming business those orange lights are
in India the traffic is all one way to
Bangladesh they say they've been living
over there for a long time but now there
are problems there and they're being
forced to leave sometimes smugglers
aren't necessary these are Indian border
force officers handing people over to
their Bangladeshi counterparts they're
all Muslim they say there's a new
hostile environment towards them in
India in decades past Bangladeshis left
their villages and cross the rice
paddies to India more than 2 million are
there now according to the government in
New Delhi in December India's Parliament
passed a fast-track
citizenship act the people from
neighboring countries that explicitly
excludes Muslims now it's impossible to
say exactly how many people are
illegally crossing the border from India
into Bangladesh but we do know that the
border force has detained more than 500
people just in the last couple of months
and the smugglers tell us they're
crossing between 40 to 60 people every
night and that's just along this 45
kilometer stretch of a border that runs
for more than 4,000 kilometers the
Indian government says its new law is
for persecuted religious minorities
living among its Muslim dominated
neighbors
that's not convinced these Bengali
speaking Muslims they say they faced
harassment from police in New Delhi in
Bangalore who told them to leave or risk
being sent to a detention centre muniya
holida says he was just 18 months old
when his parents took him across the
border 26 years ago they've been
cracking down and there been arrests 60
people from our community were detained
and we haven't heard from them
this caused panic and we decided it's
time to leave and head for Bangladesh
Kuki Begum says sheep in in India with
her husband and daughters for 11 years
that's her Indian work permit it's
absolutely clear the ruling party in
India doesn't want any Bangladeshis
living there anymore
they'll only allow Bengali speaking
Indians to live where we were what can
we do we have to live with our dignity
and honour so we came back Bangladesh is
Prime Minister Sheikh Hasina says she
doesn't understand the purpose of
India's new citizenship law our
government is already struggling to cope
with 1.2 million Ranga refugees from
Myanmar it can't afford another influx
from its largest neighbor Burnett Smith
al Jazeera on the Bangladesh India
border